hey everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight all
right from Hunter's art scam to Joe's
rabid dogs to surging GOP Contender
Vivek ramaswamy we have it all tonight
but first conflicts and corruption
that's the focus of tonight's angle
[Music]
drip drip drip well every day it seems
that important new details are trickling
out about the source of Biden's finances
and today we have potential new insights
into why that Delaware U.S attorney's
Office blocked or at least slow walked
the investigation in our hunter Biden
now courtesy of the house oversight
committee's investigation we now know
that at least one top attorney and David
Weiss's office had close personal and
professional ties to the Biden family
huh meet Alexander mackler a 2014 grad
of William and Mary Law School the
Washington examiner reports that
mackler's LinkedIn page says that he
appears to have spent years working in
the Delaware U.S attorney's Office
including during the months when
whistleblowers in the office took up an
investigation of Hunter Biden but was he
really that close to the bidens I mean
come on guys I mean this is just well
not at all he was just the press
secretary for Senator Joe Biden he was
just a legal counsel for VP Joe Biden
and in 2010 he was only the manager of
the late Beau Biden's campaign for
Delaware AG
all before joining Weiss's office as
they were kicking off the investigation
into Hunter Biden and it gets even
better
mackler worked on the Biden Harris
transition team in 2020 and even helped
the bite Administration create its wait
for it blueprint
for its Department of Justice
now in other words Alexander mackler
Andrew mackler was involved at almost
every juncture of Joe Biden's political
life for the past 15 years we're not
done yet you'll also get the mixing bowl
set thanks to trees an inflatable chair
glow sticks a shower tent six magnets an
ironing board with shirt rack and
electronic Sudoku puzzle generator
language translator mouse pad and a
mascot outfit yes there's more according
to Sarah Bedford at the Washington
examiner mackler also appeared to have a
close personal relationship with Hunter
Biden now in emails found on Hunter's
laptop mackler corresponded frequently
with Hunter Biden and also his business
associates and even referred to Hunter
fondly as a brother
now wow that sure was convenient don't
you think having mackler and Weiss's
office
and don't forget what we learned from
The Daily Mail a little more just a few
weeks back about mackler's connections
with Leslie wolf remember she was the
assistant U.S attorney who worked under
Weiss and was accused by the IRS
whistleblowers last week of stymieing
the hunter Biden investigation even
though as we know evidence they
uncovered showed really important links
between Father and Son there
now again just another Biden coincidence
I'm certain of it
while serving as Delaware Federal
prosecutor in the same office that was
investigating Hunter mackler continually
checked in on him with warm loving
emails as Hunter pursued a series of
self-con confess remember crack cocaine
and prostitute binges in a July 2018
email mackler wrote love you hope you're
good call me sometime and in October
2018 he asked Hunter how life was and
then he said give me a call sometime we
can catch up
and that's where he ended the email with
love you brother
now he was still working in the U.S
attorney's office at that time
so was there any concern in the office
about Wolf's ties to mackler well she
was investigating Hunter
a source close to the Delaware Biden
probe told the Daily Mail that mackler
worked with wolf on at least one
Delaware Federal case and that the two
were friends The Source also said there
were concerns about Wolf's ties to the
ex-biden advisor while she was
investigating Hunter and their
Collegiate relationship was even
allegedly referred to the designated
agency ethics officer for Weiss's office
we don't know what came of that though
now mackler even visited the White House
at least five times since Joe Biden
became president that's according to the
most up-to-date visitor logs that we
have this included not only one-on-ones
with Biden's campaign manager
but with the president himself
in April of 2022
clearly the Venn diagram of intersecting
characters from Biden's political shop
and the investigating team itself raise
it the very least the appearance of such
serious conflicts of interest and that
why why should have moved wolf off the
team entirely given all this
and it's another reason that Weiss's own
credibility and of course the
credibility of this entire Hunter Biden
probe is damaged Beyond repair nobody
trusts it
all of this must be pursued in serious
questioning of Mr Weiss on Capitol Hill
and I think it's yet another reason that
we desperately need the appointment of a
special counsel to review the Biden
family's involvement with all these
foreign business interests during his
time as vice president
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else